how much will German spend this holiday
season christmas is a time for joy as
consumption Germany's retailers
association estimates eighty six point
seven billion euros will be spent that's
1 billion euros more than last year a
new record although one survey suggests
every German will spend an average of
only two hundred and fifty nine euros
retailers say humbug it will be more
like 560 euros topping the list are toys
of course then come books watches
jewelry and finally consumer electronics
over a quarter of annual sales of these
items are made in the two months before
Christmas devices like tablets and
smartphones are favorites for young
people many shop owners expect their
sales to be slightly lower online
retailers enjoyed their highest sales
this season this is a boon for delivery
companies who are hiring thousands of
temporary workers to handle the crunch
sales of holiday foods are also heading
for a climax sweets chocolate gourmet
foods and of course alcoholic beverages
roasting over 10 million Christmas geese
will consume about a third more energy
than unregular days some 480 million
kilowatt hours
then there are all those things that are
indispensable to the holiday season
Christmas trees decorations and nativity
scenes a single stands serving up mulled
wine at Winter Market can earn a good
100,000 euros in four weeks Christmas is
the season of superlatives for retailers
in Germany even if all that excess can
leave consumers a little hung over